Sometimes, the most elusive anomaly in this
world is true love.
The endless carousel of blind dates, the hours
of fruitless swiping on a variety of dating
apps, and the cringe-inducing awkwardness
of bar-hopping can sometimes all be too much
to bear.
But don’t give up just yet!
If modern dating’s got you down, then we’ve
got the perfect show for you.
It’s time for some matchmaking merriment
the likes of which the world has never seen,
so sit back, relax, and get ready to fall
in love.
Live from the SCP Foundation, it’s the SCP
Dating Game!
We’ve assembled the Foundation’s most
eligible bachelors, bachelorettes, and entities
of indeterminate gender who are ready to secure,
contain, and protect your heart!
Without further ado, let’s get right to
it and meet our first fabulous contestant.
Meet SCP-096!
If you like the introverted type, then this
Bachelor might just be for you!
He prefers to keep to himself and spends most
of his time hiding his face
and crying uncontrollably
in the corner of his cell.
Isn’t it refreshing to find a guy who’s
so in touch with his emotions?
It might take some work to get him out of
his shell, but if you are patient and kind,
then you’ll be surprised at what he’s
capable of.
096 enjoys long walks
through the remote mountains,
sad movies, and being appreciated for what’s
on the inside rather than what he looks like.
Just make sure you honor his boundaries, and
never ever look at his face, and you could
be the companion this Shy Guy is looking for.
But maybe you’re looking for someone more
talkative, the kind of person who commands
the room at a dinner party with an amazing
story.
If your idea of the perfect partner is someone
who has lived a wild, fascinating, dangerous
life, then you’ll love our next dashing
contestant.
He’s SCP-1867, but you can call him Lord
Theodore Thomas Blackwood.
That’s right, not only is he charming and
bold, but he has a title, too.
Don’t be fooled by the fact that he’s
a tiny sea slug, Lord Blackwood is a master
adventurer and hunter, and he has faced some
of the most incredible and deadly things this
world has to offer!
All he wants is someone to share them with.
If you’re ready to travel across the globe
with a gentleman slug, then get ready to pack
a bag and set off on life’s great adventure
together.
Maybe you prefer your experiences to be more
digital.
No jet-setting for you, you’d rather stay
home and flirt through your phone.
If you’re into the technological side of
love, but are looking for an alternative to
the dreaded dating apps, then this next contestant
could be the one for you.
All you have to do to meet them is download
one free app: MalO ver1.0.0, and you get to
meet SCP-1471.
This is one attentive partner, they’ll text
you every few hours, and you’ll get to see
them everywhere even when they’re not really
there.
If you’re feeling a bit put off by their
skull face and shadowy body, maybe you should
work on being a bit less shallow.
Don’t judge a book by its cover, they just
really want to check-in and see how you’re
doing, and make sure you never ever feel lonely.
But hey, maybe that’s all a little too much
darkness for you.
Maybe you’re looking for someone sweeter.
Meet SCP-2396, also known as Ms. Sweetie.
She’s a lovely lady who’s all about appreciating
the bright side of life, even when things
get sour.
If you get hungry while on a date with her,
good news!
She can spontaneously generate her own hard
candy.
No more paying through the nose for movie
theater concessions, your date’s got the
snacks covered.
Now be advised, she’s not the fondest of
men, so the fellows out there might want to
steer clear, but everyone else should try
and see just how sweet life together can be.
Are you feeling lovesick, and starting to
think there might not be a cure?
Then you might need a doctor, a Plague Doctor
to be exact.
Our next eligible anomaly is SCP-049, and
not only does he have an impressive career
- I mean, come on, he’s a doctor!
- but he’s also a big believer in working
toward the greater good.
This dapper, refined Frenchman - so you know
he’s a natural romantic - believes in healing
the world, taking care of others, and making
sure everyone is feeling well.
If you’re looking for someone to heal your
heart, look no further.
This beaked bachelor has got the magic touch.
Speaking of impressive resumes, if a doctor
isn’t enough for you, then how about a king?
That’s right, the Scarlet King himself is
our next contestant.
This hunk of burning hatred is tall, dark,
and unknowable by our tiny mortal minds.
If you’re attracted to power, influence,
and unbridled evil, and don’t mind that
he’s got a few children already, then you
can take the throne by his side and reign
over chaos together.
Some people look for a partner that’s powerful
and intimidating, but others prefer an everyman.
SCP-507 is a friendly, average guy, who just
happens to be extremely well-traveled.
We’re not talking about a semester abroad
in Europe, this guy’s travel history is
completely out of this world.
He’s not afraid to be spontaneous, in fact,
he can’t stop himself from taking a trip
at a moment’s notice!
So if you’re the kind of person who’s
always looking for your next weird, wild,
exotic getaway, then 507 might be your perfect
match.
You’ve got to be willing to roll with some
weirdness though, because some of the trips
507 takes include extreme temperatures, bizarre
landscapes, and an ominous Smiling Man.
But think of the memories you’ll share that
will only bring you and your dimension-hopping
beau even closer together!
Would you like to take a walk on the wild
side?
If so, you’re in luck, because our next
Bachelorette, SCP-953, is a real fox.
No seriously, she’s a fox.
She’s highly adaptable, capable of shapeshifting,
and she loves to cook!
Her favorite dish is liver, though she prefers
to eat it raw.
She’s an elegant, charismatic lady with
an appreciation for the finer things in life
like plum wine, so why not join her for a
drink and just see where it goes?
Just be polite, don’t call her a kitsune,
and make sure your date isn’t anywhere near
a dog park.
This next eligible bachelorette is a great
fit for anyone who doesn’t place a high
value on looks.
That’s not to say she’s unattractive,
but you won’t be able to look at her.
It’s SCP-347, or Claudia, and she just so
happens to be completely invisible.
Claudia has a great sense of humor, a love
of pranks, and a variety of talents including
lock picking.
With her talent for theft, you won’t have
to worry about being the sole breadwinner!
She’s a great gal to come home to if you’re
sick of spending time alone in an empty apartment,
but still want your apartment to look like
it’s empty.
Just make sure you give any houseguests a
heads up before they come over that your home
isn’t haunted, you just have an invisible
girlfriend!
Do you like an older man?
How about a man as old as the universe itself?
Great news, here comes SCP-343, also known
as God.
This good-natured silver fox is massively
powerful and apparently omnipotent.
He knows absolutely everything about everything.
You wouldn’t be able to keep any secrets
from him, but think of how you’d wipe the
floor with everyone at bar trivia!
And up next, we have SCP-2430 - The Immortal
Hitler Clone!
Just kidding.
Can you even imagine?
Even we wouldn’t stoop that low.
Moving on!
Do you like the bad boy type?
A misanthrope?
Someone you can bond with over your shared
hatred of, well, everything?
You sound like kind of a bummer, to be honest,
but there’s an SCP match that suits you
perfectly.
SCP-682 would absolutely love to hate with
you.
This massive, extremely intelligent reptile
is one rude dude with a bad attitude.
682 is also ready for anything that life could
throw at it, capable of adapting to any situation.
Sure, this creature wants to destroy every
living thing in its path, and seems unwilling
to stop until the entire
world has been eradicated,
but come on…you can change him.
If you’re into Boston accents, then pay
close attention to our next entry: SCP-527,
a fancy little gentleman by the name of Mr.
Fish.
Why is he called Mr. Fish?
I mean, come on.
Look at him.
He’s a guy with a fish head.
He can’t breathe underwater, or talk to
other fish, or do anything unusual at all
really!
He’s just a guy from Boston, looking for
love.
He just so happens to have the head of a fish,
with a teeny little top hat.
He’s ready for any formal occasion you might
need someone to accompany you to: a wedding,
the opera, your nephew’s bar mitzvah.
But hey, if he’s not your pick, there are
plenty of fish in the sea.
Speaking of the sea, our next contestant is
one tall drink of water.
SCP-054, the water nymph, is a shapeshifting
creature made up entirely of ordinary water
that just so happens to take on the shape
of a humanoid woman.
She’d love to go swimming with you, have
a fun day at a waterpark, or play a game of
shapeshifting charades.
If that sounds like a wave you’d like to
catch, throw on a swimsuit and get ready to
dive into a future with SCP-054.
Your body is mostly water, so you two already
have a lot in common!
It's really important to have shared interests
in a romantic partnership, and if you consider
yourself a foodie, then this next contestant
is for you!
Meet SCP-082, Fernand.
Hailing from France - ooh la la!
- Fernand speaks fluent French and English.
He’s always smiling the same enormous smile,
no matter what life throws at him.
He’s tall, too, standing at approximately
8 feet, and weighing around 700 pounds.
There’s just so much of him to love!
This guy loves to cook just as much as he
loves to eat, though he’s probably not a
great fit for a vegetarian.
He loves his meat.
He also has a passion for fashion and culture,
enjoying fine clothing, television and films,
novels, and singing classical music.
This is a man with exceptional taste, and
a hunger for all of the finest things in life.
If refined gentlemen interest you, but you’re
not sure about someone with such a voracious
appetite, then this next contestant is more
your speed.
Especially if you’re a bit of an Anglophile.
Mr. Deeds can be summoned via SCP-662, or
the butler’s handbell.
If you ring it, he’ll appear, ready to attend
to your every need.
A proper English butler, Mr. Deeds is a generous
partner intent on keeping others satisfied.
He’s an especially good fit for someone
busy who needs a little help around the house.
Mr. Deeds is the perfect househusband, ready
to greet you at the door with a hot meal and
listen to you talk about your long day at
the office.
Just don’t be afraid to ask for what you
need from him!
He can’t help you if you don’t ask.
The next contestant with us today has got
some killer hair.
SCP-352, Baba Yaga, has so much going for
her.
She’s got maturity, knowledge, superhuman
healing abilities, and a bite that causes
the nervous system to shut down.
Her hobbies include cannibalism, long strolls
through the Enchanted Forest, and crafting
web-like traps out of her hair.
She’s lived long enough to know exactly
what she wants, and maybe what she wants is
you!
If you happen to speak Old Russian, and have
a taste for human flesh, then the two of you
can play house together in a lovely forest
cottage on top of some chicken legs and abduct
any unwitting travelers that wander into your
midst.
You know what they say: the couple that preys
together, stays together.
If you love an older paramour, but you’re
looking for someone with a bit more masculine
energy, then our next Bachelor is the perfect
pick.
SCP-106, or the Old Man, has traveled all
the way from his pocket dimension lair to
hunt for one thing: someone to love.
His appearance might be startling at first,
but if you give him a chance to get close
to you, he’s guaranteed to melt your heart.
This next fellow has taken some time off from
his busy professional life to come here and
compete for someone special to call his own.
He’s a career man, dedicated to his job,
but he’s also got room in his life for romance.
It’s SCP-1879, the indoor salesman!
He’s an ambitious guy with a passion for
sales, and doesn’t like to take no for an
answer.
His hobbies include sales, sales, and more
sales, in addition to appearing inside your
home when you least expect it, driving a hard
bargain, and smooth talk.
He’s a slick charmer who’s promising the
deal of a lifetime on a one-of-a-kind product:
his heart.
Maybe you don’t want a businessman, maybe
you want a guy whose career is a bit more
whimsical.
Someone with an artistic side, a sense of
humor, someone who can clown around from time
to time.
Well, you ought to meet SCP-2094, Motormouth.
He’s a multi-talented guy, skilled at juggling,
gymnastics, and acrobatics, and stretching
his lower jaw up to 2 meters in any direction
to engulf just about any item.
Never pay for storage space again, Motormouth
can store anything you need him to in his
extradimensional second stomach!
You’ll never be bored again, that’s a
guarantee.
If looks are more important
to you than personality,
like way more important, then feast your eyes
on our next competitor.
It’s SCP-056, A Beautiful Person!
What’s your type?
Tall?
Short?
Blonde, brunette, redhead?
Bearded or shaven?
It doesn’t matter!
No matter what you like, 056 will change its
shape to become appealing to you.
No one knows what this entity’s original
form looks like, but it is always gorgeous
and it always looks like the most appealing
person an observer can imagine.
Talk about knowing how to read the room!
If you have a more dominant personality, then
you should keep looking, because this entity
likes its partners on the submissive side.
It knows that it is superior to you, and wants
to make sure you know it too.
But if you’re looking for someone gorgeous
to worship, and don’t mind them being rude
all the time and knowing more than you about
everything, then you and 056 can make a life
together filled with beauty and disdain.
For our next contestant, let’s see what’s
behind Door Number Three!
It’s SCP-303!
Actually, this contestant is behind every
door, any door, anywhere.
No matter where you are, if there is a door,
it will appear on the other side.
You’ll know when it’s there, just listen
for the sound of its wheezing breathing.
That sound means you’re not alone, and you’ll
never have to be again.
Don’t be nervous, SCP-303 is more afraid
of you than you are of it.
Love is all about facing your fears, so open
up the door to your heart and let SCP-303
come inside.
Our next eligible bachelor is a little bit
prickly on the outside, but he’s got a soft
heart beneath that spiky exterior.
It’s SCP-2800, Cactusman, here to save the
day and sweep you off your feet!
His real name is Daniel MacIntyre, and yes,
he’s Scottish.
Not only does he have the DNA of a saguaro
cactus and the ability to grow spines all
over his body, he also has a super cute accent.
He’s able to conserve water as well, using
only 1/3 of the water a normal human being
would use, so he’s an ideal partner for
the particularly environmentally conscious.
He may be hot, but his body tolerates extreme
temperatures and keeps him from overheating
or becoming dehydrated!
If you had to be stranded on a desert island,
this is the man you’d want with you.
This next contestant is a real doll.
SCP-136 loves to laugh, loves attention, and
is full of surprises!
Give her a chance and she’s guaranteed to
get your heart rate up.
Good news, she’s already right behind you!
Oh wow, this is a special surprise!
We have with us here the host of another classic
show, Laugh is Fun!
Also known as SCP-2030!
Laughy McLaugherson here is a real goofball,
just a silly little prankster, who enjoys
playing jokes, watching inanimate objects
eat people alive, and making people laugh!
Laugh!
Sorry, I don’t know what came over me there.
I wasn’t really myself.
But don’t look away yet!
This contestant loves constant eye contact,
and wants to keep your undivided attention.
SCP-173 is a living work of art, a sculpture
to be exact, that can only move when it is
not being observed.
So, as long as you’re keeping an eye on
173, you’ll never lose it!
Up next is a bit of a local celebrity around
these parts: Dr. Bright!
His consciousness lives inside of an amulet
and after years of trauma he’s not the best
at opening up to people, but if you’re okay
with an emotionally long-distance relationship
you can definitely make things work!
Our final contestant is looking for someone
who loves to laugh, have fun, and get silly
once in a while.
Here comes the tickle monster!
It’s SCP-999.
This gelatinous gem wants nothing more than
to cheer you up, give you a big hug, and make
sure you’re having a wonderful day.
999 has a world of love to share, and simply
coming into contact with its slimy surface
is enough to make you smile.
Not only does 999 help people feel better,
but it smells good to everyone who meets it,
bringing a comforting aroma to your shared
home.
You don’t have to worry about cooking for
it, either, as its diet consists entirely
of candy.
Every day is a new chance to laugh and play
with SCP-999, if it tickles your fancy!
And heck, if you’re so eager to hang out
with SCP-999 that you don’t even want to
wait for a date, you can always go to scpswag.com
and get yourself a high-quality SCP-999 plushie!
Just saying!
So, who’s your lucky date going to be?
Do you want to play it safe, or take a walk
on the wild side?
Take a weekend trip with SCP-507, or try to
convince SCP-682 that you’re the only human
out there who isn’t “disssgussting?”
Let us know your pick in the comments below
and let your love story finally begin.
And then go check out “SCP-2521 ●●|●●●●●|●●|● and
Infohazard SCPs Explained” and “SCP-999
Tickle Monster VS.
the Most Evil SCPs” for more of our delightful
and terrifying SCP compilations!